غضب الشارع الايراني لا يزال حاضرا
والاحتجاجات مستمره بعد دعوه مجموعه
شبابيه للطلاب والعمال الاضراب والنزول
الى الشوارع في كل انحاء البلاد وتحويل
يوم الطالب الذي يتم احيائه سنويا الى يوم
رعب بالنسبه للدوله دعوه تزامنت مع زياره
الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيس لجامعه
للقاء خطاب بالمناسبه
مدير الشباب
قبل ثلاثه اشهر بتهمه خلق قواعد اللباس في
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه تعيش ايران وعلى واقع
احتجاجات غير مسبوقه ومسيره غاضبه من
القوانين المفروض على النساء وسعاده من
حده مطلب
في وقت تحاول فيه السلطات الايرانيه
السيطره على الوضع الرئيس الايراني
مستبدرين الولايات المتحده هي الدوله
الاكثر استبدادا واكبر دكتاتوريه في
العالم الصوت الحقيقي للطالب الايراني
معاذ لامريكا
وعلى الرغم من قطع الحكومه للانترنت
والشهادات النادره عما يحدث في البلاد
وتصريح السلطات الايرانيه عن الغاء جهاز
الشرطه الاخلاق المثير للجدل الا ان
الاحتجاجات لم تضعف ووحدت كل الاختلافات
العرقيه والدينيه في البلاد